GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE." WE HAVE JUST
HEARD FROM THE WHITE HOUSE AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP SOUNDED OFF
AGAIN ABOUT THE RAIDS INVOLVING
HIS PERSONAL ATTORNEY AND THE
RUSSIA PROBE.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN CLEAR
THAT HE HAS DEEP CONCERN ABOUT
THE DIRECTION OF THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
THIS INVESTIGATION STARTED OFF
AS RORSCHACH COLLUSION OF WHICH
THERE WAS NONE.
IT'S BEEN CLEAR NOTHING HAS COME
UP OVER THE LAST YEAR, AND THE
PRESIDENT HAS SPOKEN AT LENGTH
ON THIS TOPIC.
THE MEDIA CONTINUES TO FOCUS ON
IT DESPITE THE FACT THAT THERE'S
BEEN NO EVIDENCE AFTER A YEAR,
WE ARE GOING TO STAY FOCUSED ON
THE ISSUES.
>> Jesse: THE PRESIDENT FIRED
OFF A SERIOUS TWEET, CALLING THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION FAKE AND
CORRUPT, HEADED UP BY ALL OF THE
DEMOCRAT LOYALISTS.
HE SAID THAT MUELLER IS MOST
CONFLICTED OF ALL EXCEPT
ROSENSTEIN WHO SIGNED THE FISA
AND COMEY LETTER."
SARAH SANDERS SAID YESTERDAY IT
IS WITHIN MR. TRUMP'S
JURISDICTION TO DO SO.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN CLEAR THAT HE THINKS THIS
HAS GONE TOO FAR.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE HE HAS THE
POWER TO FIRE SPECIAL COUNSEL
ROBERT MUELLER?
>> I CERTAINLY BELIEVE HE HAS
THE POWER TO DO SO.
>> Jesse: KIMBERLY, LET'S
START WITH THE RAID THAT WE
DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO TALK
ABOUT THE OTHER DAY.
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN INVESTIGATING
FOR ALMOST TWO YEARS.
HAVE NOT FOUND EVIDENCE OF A
CRIME OR RUSSIAN OCCLUSION
EVIDENCE.
NOW THEY ARE GOING INTO HIS
PERSONAL ATTORNEY TO I GUESS
LOOK FOR PAYMENTS TO STORMY
DANIELS.
NOW IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S AN FEC
VIOLATION.
WHERE DO YOU THINK THAT IS
HEADED?
>> Kimberly: CAN YOU IMAGINE,
THE INSPECTION WHERE THIS
INVESTIGATION WAS SUPPOSED TO GO
ON WHERE IT'S TRAVELED.
FAR BEYOND THE ORIGINAL INITIAL
SCOPE.
YOU COME ACROSS SOMETHING WHILE
YOU'RE DOING AN INVESTIGATION,
THAT'S ONE THING.
NEVERTHELESS, THERE'S BEEN A
WIDE SWATH AND NET CAST, TRYING
TO GET ANYTHING THEY CAN, IT
SEEMS, IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
BRING SOMETHING AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT THROUGH MICHAEL COHEN.
OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
OVERLOOK IF THERE'S ANY
WRONGDOING.
BUT NEVERTHELESS, LET ME TELL
YOU SOMETHING.
I HAD A CASE WHERE I PROSECUTED
FOR HOMICIDE.
COMPLICATED BECAUSE ALL OF THE
THINGS IN THEIR HOUSE WHEN WE
HAVE THE SEARCH WARRANT ISSUED
HAD PRIVILEGED, CALM THE DIGITAL
INFORMATION.
YOU HAVE TO GO THROUGH ALL THE
DOCUMENTS TO MAKE SURE YOU ARE
NOT TAKING ANYTHING IMPROPERLY.
>> Jesse: THE CLEAN TEAM.
>> Kimberly: THAT'S HOW THEY
REFER TO IT HERE.
THEY HAD TO GO THROUGH HIS HOTEL
OFFICE.
THEY GOT A JUDGE TO SIGN OFF ON
IT.
THEY HAVE TO HAVE AND THEY
BETTER HAVE SOME REALLY
COMPELLING PROBABLE CAUSE AND
EVIDENCE TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
IT.
EVERY AMERICAN, DOESN'T MATTER
IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT,
REPUBLICAN, LIBERTARIAN, LEANING
GREEN, WHATEVER YOU WANT TO DO,
THIS CAN HAPPEN TO YOU AS WELL.
THE SAFEGUARDS OF THE LOG
CONSIST FOR A REASON SO THEY
WILL NOT BE ABUSED TO PROTECT
THE RIGHTS OF AMERICAN CITIZENS.
GUESS WHAT, INCLUDING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
AND AS PERSONAL LEGAL COUNSEL.
LET'S SEE WHAT THEY ARE ABLE TO
IT'S AGGRESSIVE AND
HEAVY-HANDED.
THERE ISN'T ANY LEGAL SCHOLAR I
LISTEN TO THE DOESN'T AGREE THIS
IS AN AGGRESSIVE MOVE.
REALLY UNPRECEDENTED.
>> Jesse: ALAN DERSHOWITZ SAID
THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OF
MICHAEL COHEN WERE VIOLATED.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING IT'S A LITTLE
UNFAIR WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOW
HILLARY CLINTON WAS TREATED.
MICHAEL COHEN HAS BEEN
COOPERATING WITH THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
HE'S PRODUCED ALMOST A MILLION
DOCUMENTS.
THEN THEY RAIDED HIS HOUSE.
HILLARY CLINTON TREADED A LOT OF
PEOPLE THINK THERE'S A LITTLE
BIT OF AN UNFAIRNESS FACTOR.
>> Dana: PERHAPS.
DOJ INSPECTOR GENERAL MICHAEL
HOROWITZ IS INVESTIGATING THAT
PIECE MICHAEL COHEN HIMSELF SAID
YESTERDAY ON TELEVISION THAT THE
FBI WAS VERY COURTEOUS AND
RESPECTFUL.
HE HAD NO PROBLEM WITH IT, HE
DOESN'T LIKE IT.
HE SAID IT WASN'T PLEASANT BUT
THERE IS THAT.
THEN YOU FIND OUT ABOUT THE
PROCESS AND THE HIGH BAR YOU
HAVE TO CLEAR WITH A JUDGE AND
OTHERS, INCLUDING POLITICAL
APPOINTEES LIKE ROD ROSENSTEIN
HAD TO SIGN OFF ON THIS TYPE OF
THING.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT REALLY IS ALL
ABOUT STORMY DANIELS.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
BUT THE WHOLE PAYMENT SITUATION,
WHATEVER HAPPENED WITH
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
FINDING OUT THE INFORMATION IN
JANUARY, ISSUING THE STORY, THEN
SHE COMES FORWARD.
ALL OF THIS STUFF IS COMING
TOGETHER.
ALL OF THAT HAPPENED BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
BUT IF THEY BROUGHT IT INTO THE
PRESIDENCY, AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO FIND, I
THINK THE COUNTRY HAS A LOT
GOING ON WITH MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS, LIKE WE'RE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT IN THE NEXT SEGMENT.
POSSIBLE MILITARY ACTION AGAINST
A REALLY BAD ACTOR.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE SYSTEM IS
WORKING IT IS, WORKING THE WAY
IT IS SUPPOSED TO.
>> Jesse: ON A TECHNICALITY,
YOU ARE RIGHT, IT IS.
IF YOU MAKE UP PAYMENT TO
SOMEONE FOR $130,000 IN THE
MIDST OF A CAMPAIGN AND YOU
DON'T REPORTED TO THE FEC, I
GUESS IT IS SOME SORT OF
CAMPAIGN FINANCE VIOLATION.
YOU CAN SERVE UP TO FIVE YEARS
IN PRISON AND FACE UP TO $25,000
IN FINES.
THAT COULD BE HOW THEY ARE
TRYING TO SQUEEZE COHEN, MOVIE
TO FLIP ON DONALD TRUMP.
>> Greg: DIDN'T SOMETHING
HAPPEN SIMILAR WITH OBAMA AND A
CAMPAIGN VIOLATION.
THEY HAD TO PAY FINE.
YOU CAN LOOK IT UP.
THEY BROUGHT UP DERSHOWITZ.
HE IS NO FAN OF TRUMP.
I DON'T EVEN THINK HE THINKS
TRUMP IS A GOOD PRESIDENT.
BUT I HAVEN'T SEEN ONE PERSON
DISAGREE WITH DERSHOWITZ WITHOUT
FIRST IMPUGNING HIS MOTIVES.
THAT'S ALWAYS A SIGN FOR ME THAT
THEY CAN'T ARGUE WITH
DERSHOWITZ.
IF YOU HAVE TO GO STRAIGHT TO
INSULTING HIM, THAT'S WHEN YOU
KNOW YOU ARE WINNING.
HERE IS THE NARRATIVE.
YOU HAVE THE OUTSIDER ELECTED TO
DISRUPT THE SYSTEM AND BOY, DID
HE.
IT'S A TRULY RADICAL PRESIDENCY
AND WE ARE WATCHING IT ALL OVER
THE PLACE, FROM NORTH KOREA TO
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH CHINA.
THE SYSTEM IS DISRUPTIVE.
THE MEDIA IS CONVULSING.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
WANDERING IN A HAZE.
THE OPPOSITION IS GOING THROUGH
ALL THEIR TOOLS.
THEY FIND A WEAPON THEY WEREN'T
ORIGINALLY LOOKING FOR TO REMOVE
HIM, AND IT IS SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED BEFORE THE ELECTION.
NOTHING I SAID HERE IS FALSE.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S HAPPENING.
WE HAD A RADICAL ELECTED TO THE
GOVERNMENT WHO HAS DISRUPTED THE
SYSTEM AND NOW THERE'S AN
OPPOSITION TRYING TO UNSEAT HIM
WITH SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
>> Kimberly: THEY TRIED TO DO
IT WITH THE ACCESS HOLLYWOOD
TAPE.
>> Greg: THE PUBLIC IS GOING
TO SENSE THIS.
I HAVE TO WONDER IF THE
ANTI-TRUMP-ERS ARE THINKING THIS
ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
THE PUBLIC WILL SENSE THAT THIS
IS A POLITICAL COUP USING PAST
PERSONAL BEHAVIOR.
THIS IS GOING TO TURN
DONALD TRUMP INTO A FOLK HERO, A
COMBINATION OF JOHNNY APPLESEED
AND PAUL BUNYAN BECAUSE HE'S
GOING TO APPEAR TO BE THE VICTIM
BECAUSE YOU ARE TAKING HIM OUT,
NOT OVER POLICY.
YOU ARE TAKING THEM OUT OVER
PERSONAL BEHAVIOR THAT OCCURRED
PRIOR TO THE ELECTION.
IF YOU HATE TRUMP, GET A LOAD OF
PENCE.
HE IS GOING TO MAKE
RONALD REAGAN LOOK LIKE A B
HOFFMAN.
-- ABBIE HOFFMAN.
>> Jesse: ANY --
>> Juan: IT WOULD BE A
TREMENDOUS ACT OF INDISCRETION.
I ASKED ALL OF YOU CAN CONSIDER,
THE PEOPLE WHO APPROVED THIS ARE
REPUBLICAN.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT THE FBI
DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER WRAY, ROD
ROSENSTEIN, A TRUMP APPOINTEE AS
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL.
TALKING ABOUT JEFFREY BERMAN,
THE U.S. ATTORNEY IN NEW YORK,
THEY HAD TO APPROVE OF THIS STEP
OF THE FBI GOING INTO COHEN'S
HOTEL ROOM.
>> Jesse: DID BERMAN RECUSE?
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW THAT.
WHAT I DO KNOW IS THAT TRUMP IN
ESSENCE BROUGHT THIS ON HIMSELF.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
HATE TRUMP AND ALL THAT BUT IT
WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO SAID
LAST WEEK THAT HE KNEW NOTHING
ABOUT THE PAYMENT OF MONEY BY
MICHAEL: , TECHNICALLY HIS LAWYE
MICHAEL: , TECHNICALLY HIS LAWYR
MICHAEL: , TECHNICALLY HIS LAWY.
SOME PEOPLE SAY HE'S HIS FIXER,
TO THIS WOMAN, STEPHANIE
CLIFFORD, STORMY DANIELS.
THEN IT TURNS OUT THAT ONCE HE
SAYS THAT, THERE IS NO
LAWYER-CLIENT PRIVILEGE BECAUSE
IF THAT'S THE CASE, HE IS NOT
REPRESENTING THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IS NOW IN A POSITION WHERE HE IS
EITHER LYING ABOUT NOT KNOWING
ABOUT THIS MONEY OR THERE IS
SOME SECRET THAT A FACTOR WHO
HAS GIVEN MONEY FOR THIS AND
THEREFORE HAS LEVERAGE TO
POTENTIALLY BLACKMAIL THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
WHICH IS WHY I THINK IT HAS SET
OFF ALARMS NOT ONLY IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT NATIONWIDE.
>> Jesse: OKAY, LET'S TALK
ABOUT ROSENSTEIN.
YOU SAID HE'S A REPUBLICAN, AND
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS APPROVE
THIS.
HE DOES HAVE SOME CONFLICTS.
WE KNOW THE PRESIDENT MENTIONED
THOSE DURING HIS TWEET STORM, AS
THEY LIKE TO SAY.
HE IS OVERSEEING AN
INVESTIGATION OF OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE WITH FIRING OF JAMES
COMEY AND HE WAS ONE WHO
AUTHORED THE LETTER
RECOMMENDING THE FIRING OF JAMES
COMEY AND HE WAS THE ONE WHO
APPOINTED MUELLER.
HE ALSO SIGNED OFF ON THE
SURVEILLANCE WARRANTS.
NOW HIS OWN DEPARTMENT'S
STONEWALLING CONGRESS TO FIND
THE DOCUMENTATION FOR THE
WARRANT.
NOW HE IS OVERSEEING THIS ENTIRE
INVESTIGATION.
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE WAY HILLARY WAS TREATED
AND YOU LOOK AT THE CONFLICTS
ROSENSTEIN HAS, THE PRESIDENT
FEELS LIKE HE'S BEING UNFAIRLY
TREATED HERE, KIMBERLY.
THE RULES APPLY TO OTHER PEOPLE
THAT DON'T APPLY TO OTHER HIM.
>> Kimberly: HE HAS BEEN VOCAL
AND TRANSPARENT ABOUT HIS UPSET
AND THE FACT THAT HE THINKS THIS
WAS UNFAIR THAT THIS
INVESTIGATION WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
ABOUT ONE THING BUT NOW IT SEEMS
TO BE VERY PERSONAL TO TRY TO
UNSEAT THE AMERICAN PRESIDENT,
DULY ELECTED.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO FEEL VERY
STRONGLY ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
YOU HAVE SEEN SOME REACTION AND
GREG HAS TOUCHED ON IT.
NOW HE IS FACED WITH ANOTHER
DECISION WHICH IS IT'S AN
ONGOING INVESTIGATION.
WHAT DOES HE DO ABOUT IT?
WHAT IS HE LEGALLY ABLE TO DO,
WHAT'S WITHIN HIS RIGHTS, AND
WHAT'S POLITICALLY SMART FOR HIM
TO DO?
THERE ARE SOME DECISIONS HERE
THAT WOULD BE A PROBLEM FOR HIM
IF HE WERE TO FIRE MUELLER.
THEN THERE'S THE OPTION WHICH IS
WIDELY DISCUSSED OVER THE LAST
24 HOURS AS TO WHETHER OR NOT HE
SHOULD REMOVE ROSENSTEIN DUE TO
SOME CONFLICTS OF INTEREST THAT
HAVE PRESENTED ACROSS-THE-BOARD
HERE IN TERMS OF SOME OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
TIE-INS TO COMEY, MUELLER,
WHAT'S GOING ON, SHOULD THERE BE
ANOTHER SPECIAL COUNSEL ASSIGNED
TO INVESTIGATE THAT, WHETHER
THERE WAS ANY KIND OF
UNDERHANDED THINGS GOING ON OR
SOME COLLUSION THERE IN TERMS OF